Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god, I am... I am so excited right now to be here.
I literally just got back from my fan-made panel like 10 minutes ago, so now I'm here.
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Ah, huge shout out to Marble Rivals for this opportunity to check out the early access of Ultron and season 2.5.
So, oh my gosh, I'm so nervous, everyone.
But thank you, everybody, for all the gifted subs!
Oh my god, thank you for the raid, Gomez!
Thank you, thank you, everyone!
Yes, I will be checking out everything very, very, very soon.
There is a lot of stuff to look into, so I'm very, very excited.
Marco, thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, everybody!
Like you guys said, I still don't have my third monitor yet, so I might be very slow in reading stuff right now because I only have two monitors instead of three.
Wow, Doki, only two monitors?
Wow!
Look, I've been streaming so long for three monitors!
It's weird!
I can't, I have everything cramped into my second monitor right now!
Like all the things I have to say and everything!
Anyway, for those who don't know, I pinned a link to my rivals.
If you guys have not checked out the game yet, please feel free to click on the link.
It does help out a lot.
And download the game and you think it looks fun!
Anyway, uh, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Uh, so there is, Marvel's season 2.5 is coming out, um, on May 30th, very, very, very soon.
Uh, but we do have, very thankful to Marvel Rivals for sponsoring this stream, so that, and giving me the opportunity to check it out early for you guys, so you know what to look out for!
Uh, so a lot of things are coming out.
It is free to play, and all the heroes are unlocked right away.
And the newest hero for this season, sorry, for next season is Ultron!
Yes, the newest support character!
Um, I finally binded my descent key just so I could play Ultron, because you guys know I am a support player for Marvel Rivals.
And, um, I had unbinded my descent key, so every time I had to go down, I looked down.
I had to, I had to look down to move, go down.
But now, now I finally binded, I can't do that anymore!
I, so my descent key is finally binded, because there finally is a, a, there's finally a support character that flies, so I cannot do that anymore.
But yes, there is a lot, always new updates coming in.
Um, you guys didn't know, they always add a new hero every, uh, every, uh, season change.
So, like, season two, season two or five, season one, season 1.5, they always add a new hero.
So we get, like, two new heroes per season.
Um, and so there's so many new updates and everything, and all the new, there's gonna be so many things to check out!
But, before we check that out, we're gonna watch some trailers!
Please let me know if the volume is okay!
Hey, hey, hey!
Um, but, oh yeah, if you guys are like, Ultron doesn't seem very supportive, you're sort of right, because I will show you guys why.
You're not very wrong, but we'll show you guys the trailers for the new map, and Ultron itself.
So yes, let me, uh, let me put that up here.
Boom!
This is, I don't remember what this, oh, there's Ultron!
So Ultron is, uh, one of the support, the new flyer support.
So his left click, by the way, I'll tell you guys right now, there's no, there's, there's barely falloff for his left click.
I was on the other side of the training arena.
I was, I was on the other side, and I was going, pew!
You know, like, I was like, pew!
I'll let you guys know that right now.
It's going to be very fun to see.
I was like, oh, that's silly.
But I know, if I was on the other side of that, I'll be like, wait, that's not silly no more.
Actually, I have not checked out the new map, so that's going to be new for me.
Like, actually 100% new.
So, so the sister, I love Krakoa.
Can't wait to check this one out.
I actually have not looked at the map.
I think it's silly when I play Ultron, but I know it's not going to be silly when I'm not, when that enemy Ultron does that to me.
Is it payload?
I don't know.
Good question.
I actually don't know.
That was the one I didn't check out.
I was looking through everything.
So I was like, okay, well, should I look, look out for it?
When I like, uh, look at everything.
And just to see, make sure I got everything down.
Um, to show you guys.
And like, I actually did not look at the new map.
So I'm just as curious as you guys.
It looks really cool though.
It's only funny when it happens to someone else.
Yeah, that's basically it.
I was like, not funny no more.
This is not funny.
Um, I heard there's also like a lot of new cosmetics and everything.
All right.
Enough.
Enough talking without the game.
It's time to show you guys the game now.
All right.
Oh, I'm so excited.
This should be it.
Okay, let me log in real quick, guys.
I forgot to log in.
I knew I forgot something.
Anonymous Gifter.
Thank you for the gift itself.
I really appreciate it.
Oh yeah, let me change the volume.
I realized the game has no volume.
Oopsie.
All right, there you go.
All right.
So yes, the new costume.
So there's the new Hawkeye free costume for Hawkeye.
Because Hawkeye is a little broken.
And so these are all the, you guys gotta complete these challenges to get the new Hawkeye costume.
And then there's this one too.
The combat chest.
Anonymous Gifter.
Thank you for the 20 gifted subs.
Thank you.
So there's all the, there's Magneto.
Um, there's Storm.
Um, and then there's, uh, uh, Mr. Fantastic.
Oh, wait, what's the... No, I want to see.
I want to see open.
What's the make it real?
Okay, I like that one.
Normally, I don't use emotes, but that's a good emote right there.
I feel like people are gonna abuse this emote during the lobby.
And you, when you get Iron Man in there, get Iron Man and Emma Frost, and then we're gonna have a party.
Oh, wait, that's so cool.
And Venom!
Oh my god, you're right.
Iron Man, Venom, and Emma Frost.
The perfect emote combo.
The roleplay meta is evolving, guys.
Oh my god, I cannot wait for the roleplay meta in my doom lobbies.
When I'm in the doom queues.
When I'm waiting in, on, in the doom lobbies, waiting for my match.
I cannot wait.
Oh, cool.
Okay, so there's the other new emote.
There's the, uh, oh, that's the emote for Mr. Fantastic.
So it's basically future foundation.
What I thought was cool, okay, I think, let's see if this works.
But it gives you a preview of the other skins too, which I thought.
So you get to see the future foundation of, um, I, I don't know if that's spy, is that Spider-Man over there?
Over there at the, yeah, I think this is, this is the battle.
Uh, yeah, this has to be the, yeah, is that Spider-Man?
Where's the human torch?
Did they, like, they replaced, sorry, Johnny.
We have, he was like, sorry, Johnny, my new brother, Spider-Man.
He replaced Johnny.
Um, uh, okay, and then there's Magneto.
Uh, we have Magneto right here.
Wait, what?
No, I, it's just fake.
We all know it's not real.
We all know he's not actually dead.
In superhero, in superhero lore, no one's actually dead dead, guys.
Also, I noticed, um, what I noticed that was really interesting was, uh, we have to show you guys.
Where is it?
It was like a, um, where was it?
I saw, oh yeah, there was something really interesting.
By the way, this is my new name now.
Oh, here, you can put this next to your name plates.
Um, it's not muted.
It's just really, there's not really any sound right now.
I'm my number one fan, guys.
It's not muted.
I, I had, um, there's not really much volume right now.
So, you can, there's like barely any volume in this game at the moment.
So, it's not really muted, because it's the main.
But I thought this was really cute.
Um, I also turn a lot of the sound stuff, like, low, too.
Uh, like, see the master volume?
I have a lot of it very low.
So, uh, let me turn it back up, though.
Well, well, well, to how I usually do it.
I'll turn it up a little bit.
Uh, buh, buh, buh.
Oh, I like music.
I'll turn the music up.
Back up.
All right.
There we go.
That should be good.
Uh, all right.
I'll let you guys listen to this stuff again.
Oh, there's... Let it rain.
Oh, yeah, you guys want to see the, this part.
Yay!
There we go.
Is that volume better now?
All right, so there's that.
And I believe... Okay, so...
I did buy the Ultron, new Ultron skin.
Because, like, I was curious on what it looked like, because it looked pretty cool.
I don't know which one I like.
I don't know.
I don't know if I like this one.
Or... I don't know if I like the original or the Extron.
They both look good in its own way.
And then there's this, the alternative, the mechanical, uh, phantom.
This, this one looks very clean.
Uh, can you show his lord icon?
Yeah.
That's his... I believe... Wait.
There you go.
That's his lord icon.
Wow!
I don't know.
Like, the original one just looks really clean.
And so, like, it's so hard to see which one I like.
Also, a little, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
And then we have, like, you know, the gamer energy drink Ultron.
It's K, I don't know.
Or the quad.
Like, P. It's like, do I want to be a gamer today?
Or, or, or, or what?
Um, all right.
So, I'll show you guys what, um, what I mean.
Okay, wait.
Let me see.
I need to make sure I follow, uh, let's see.
I'm gonna go through everything to make sure I got everything, got everything I need to check out.
Oh, yeah.
Here you go.
That's the normal battle pass.
This is, like, extra.
The combat chest.
Instantly get one reward.
Let's go.
Yay!
Now I can equip... Hi!
What do I use this for?
Wait, I should buy this.
I'll buy this.
I just want this.
Not gonna...
That's all I want for now.
That's all I want.
Of course.
Oh, it's the new emotes.
Oh, my gosh.
It's...
Sometimes it feels like you guys know more than me, but I didn't read the patch notes.
I was trying... gonna enjoy.
I was gonna, like, figure it out as I go along.
But thank you for letting me out.
Yeah, Emma's making it rain.
Marco, thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Sometimes I just don't read the patch notes, guys.
I just...
Readings for nerds.
Exactly!
Oh, exactly!
That's what I'm saying!
Why read when I can be told what to do?
That's why I became a streamer!
That's the whole point of streaming!
Being yelled at and told what to do!
Alright, okay, so I'm gonna show you guys...
I'll show you guys what I mean, but...
Okay, guys.
Alright, I'll show you guys.
This is my favorite part.
Alright, so...
See that?
Now watch me move further away.
Watch me slowly move further away!
And then...
Watch me continue to move further away!
What is the range, you might ask?
Yes!
I think that's funny.
That's... that's the silly thing.
It's so silly.
The range...
The range is...
Yes!
Okay, so...
You wanna know what's even sillier?
Let me show you.
It's also...
Let me show you what's even sillier, guys.
Alright, so...
Okay, it's his team up.
So when you get Iron Man...
Um...
When you...
Let me show you guys.
So...
Alright...
So there's Iron Man, right?
So he has...
He has a special team up, guys.
So if you guys...
Don't go.
Alright, you see that guy?
So this is his team up.
And I can...
Heal and damage at the same time.
Right?
Alright, so imagine this.
You died.
It's overtime.
You have the Iron Man power-up.
Wha...
Alright, watch my...
This guy dies first.
You died.
Save the game.
Yeah, you're slowly getting over to your team.
You're slowly trying to get to your team.
You're all the way from spawn, but it's okay.
You have an Iron Man.
And then you kill him.
You can shoot through your teammate to kill him too.
So you see a person is in front of you.
It's cooking.
And then you can shoot through your own teammate to heal him.
To kill somebody.
His left click doesn't heal.
The only way to heal is this.
So this is the E.
This is the only way to heal.
This is literally your only heal button.
Also your right click too.
Your right click heals as well.
But oh yeah, so... So his ult... You know what's funny?
What I realized about his ult?
It's like...
Where's the real Ultron?
It's gonna be so hard to shoot... Also this heals too.
It's gonna be very hard to shoot the real Ultron.
But this is... I'm not pressing any buttons by the way.
This is automatic.
This is all automatic.
So I'm not pressing any buttons.
It just keeps going.
But that's his ult.
I also have no cooldowns on right now.
Yeah, it's auto.
It's auto.
So yeah, that's the fun part.
So the shield is basically... I put this on.
And no matter where I go... Okay, wait.
Let me make...
Okay, so... Let me see this.
I put that on.
And I put it on him.
And then wherever I am going...
He gets healed.
But the thing is that... There's a range.
I found out.
So...
You can't put it on a flanker.
You have to put it on a person.
Because if you don't, it... It just goes like out of range.
Because there's a range to it.
See?
So that's good.
So you don't have to... So you...
Flinkers aren't people.
They're not real.
I will not acknowledge Psylocke.
Yes, this is an AoE heal.
So whoever's... If this guy is in his drone thing...
He gets healed.
But this guy gets more of the healing.
And everything.
So...
How could she say that?
Alright, so...
That's all...
I want to show you guys on Ultron.
Because those are...
That's like the most interesting part.
Um... But like...
Okay, I keep going back to the spawn for this...
Okay, but like people are saying that Jeff...
He made Jeff shitty now.
No.
Because...
Let me show you this.
Team up.
Watch this.
Watch this guys.
This is a very interesting team up.
He's dead.
He...
And watch how much damage it did to this guy.
He's almost dead.
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha.
That.
Ha hou ha ha!
So, whenever...
Whoever I ate...
Gets hurt in the stormal.æse So he's dead.
Whoever... Ha hi ha ha.
So this is a second guy.
And he's...
This is the second guy that I got eaten.
Cause he respawned.
Happy to help.
So when I eat somebody, whoever I eat... dies in the Storm ult.
The Storm ult damages, damages whoever is inside my belly.
And then Storm gets 12 seconds of ult.
Because she gets an extra 6 seconds of her ult.
Oh yeah, this is one of my favorite too.
Look how fast... okay, I'll show you guys.
Look how fast I heal this guy.
They're full healed.
Look how fast that was.
One, two, three, four.
And they get over here.
Oh, but this is my favorite too.
Wait, let me show you.
Okay, watch this.
Shoot me.
Alright.
Yo, I'll show you guys the visualization of this.
Because it's pretty neat.
It's... it's pretty neat.
Alright, he has to go yummy yummy.
Yummy yummy.
Come on.
Yummy yummy me.
Yummy yummy.
The bubbles don't stack by the way.
Watch.
Shielding never hurts.
Yay!
Did you guys see how fast that was?
Whoa!
Okay.
Yeah!
Isn't that crazy?
I was like, whoa!
That's pretty funny.
And then I think...
And then like...
I'm pretty sure everyone else was like, that's not funny.
And then...
He would be like...
Doki no.
That's not funny.
But I was like...
Oh wait.
That's pretty funny.
Yeah!
Alright.
Let me show you this.
This one was funny.
Wait, wait.
I'll show you something even funnier.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Oh wait.
Guys, I'll show you something even funnier, guys.
Let me head over there real fast.
Watch this, guys.
It's pretty funny.
Let me...
I'll be here.
Watch this.
Oh my god.
I don't play lock, guys.
So I'm...
There you go.
Oh my god.
Please.
I can't.
That's okay.
I can shoot through the walls.
There's no way.
It's pretty funny.
It goes through everything, by the way.
Let me show you guys what I mean.
Very...
Ha ha.
Fun.
Yeah.
And the further you are, the more damage you do.
So you see that guy?
Wait.
Where is he?
Where even is he?
Oh my god.
I don't know where he is.
I think I need to, like, figure him out.
Okay, guys.
I need to figure out where he is, guys.
Where is he?
Where is he on that...
area?
Oh wait.
There's a range, right?
Where is he?
Ha ha ha.
I don't know where he is!
Don't go.
Where is he?
Wait, did I hit him?
Heads up, bad guys!
I don't even know!
Where did he go?
Oh, there...
Oh, he's over...
Guys, it's just I missed.
I don't know where he is.
Because there's a wall.
I don't know if you guys noticed this, but there's a wall.
There we go.
Okay, now I know where he is.
I...
Ha ha ha.
Wait, do I actually?
Oh, there he is.
Alright.
I need to have walls.
I don't know where he is.
Ha ha ha.
It doesn't feel like...
Sometimes I don't know where he is.
But the further you are, the more damage you do, apparently.
Look.
Okay, I figured it out.
There he is.
There we go.
We figured out where he is.
Ha ha ha.
I don't see a wall up there.
Alright, there...
Oh, oh, it's right here!
Guys, did you see that?
It's right here!
Alright!
Get that!
Whoa!
There we go.
Actual one and a half.
So you can shoot through walls now.
It's the...
Bro.
Alright.
It's great.
Now you gotta figure out who to ban.
Isn't that great?
Ha ha ha ha.
There's so many things.
Alright.
And then there's...
Oh yeah, the team up.
Let me show you guys the team up for...
For Venom.
So it's like...
Basically he...
When I press X...
He does this.
Be healed!
Yes!
Also, this doesn't stack, by the way.
This does not stack.
So it's like...
I think it's like 4 seconds or something?
Yeah, so that's the Venom team up.
So like, I can heal like 6 people at the same time.
Yay!
But they have to be close to me.
Because this is the range.
So it's like...
Be healed!
That's right!
Heal yourself!
Now!
Nova!
Thank you for tier 1!
So thank you, thank you!
But yeah.
That's basically it.
But this...
This is like...
4 seconds, I believe.
1, 2, 3, 4...
Or 5...
6 seconds?
Or is it 6 seconds?
Yeah, alright.
But it's like...
Boom.
So it's just that.
Yay!
Obviously there's a limit to it.
And then you see the bar?
I can't stay under for too long.
Someone hold me!
I'm scared!
Oh!
Wait!
Oh, watch this!
Watch this, guys!
Look how fast I am now!
I'm so fast now!
Can't kill me this time!
I'm zooming!
I'm so fast I can run now!
His one weakness was that he was very slow.
They also buffed his damage too.
He has legs!
He can finally run!
It's crazy!
He doesn't leisurely walk!
It's great!
Now you have to figure out what to ban!
What else can I show you guys?
He runs!
Finally!
He has legs!
Rocket Penny?
I guess.
I think this...
I don't think this is quite useful.
Only because, like, if I use this for a res...
Everyone will know where my res is.
So, like...
I don't know.
I feel like people will know where my res is when I use it.
So, I don't know.
I don't know how useful this really is because of it.
Um...
But it's...
I mean, it's for Penny to have two things.
Yeah.
Uh...
Yeah, I feel like it's gonna be found much more easily.
And then they're still just gonna destroy it in general.
Uh...
So...
Penny...
Yeah, it's just for...
I feel like it's more so for Penny-wise.
Oh, yeah.
I'll show you the team up for Widow.
It goes through, by the way.
Watch.
See?
I...
I think it pierces, right?
No, it doesn't pierce.
Sorry.
JK.
It doesn't pier...
Wait, does it?
No, it does.
I think it pierces.
You have to zoom in, though.
Let me get rid of these.
You have to...
You have to zoom in.
It does.
Okay, so...
It pierces.
That's basically it.
And you can't...
Yeah.
Oh my god!
He went from...
She went from F tier to D tier.
Oh my god, guys.
We did it.
We...
We did it, guys.
She went up one tier.
We...
Improvement.
Oh my god.
I think this is the serious.
Nobody can shoot a gun.
This is what made me laugh the most.
That takes skill.
This one is the silliest of them all.
Wait, can I do this?
So silly.
That is very silly.
I know like, when it happens to me, it's no longer gonna be silly anymore.
Lucky for you guys, the cooldown for it is 20 seconds.
Yeah.
It's 20 seconds.
It's 20 second cooldown.
So...
It's not that bad, but it's...
Imagine if you're just...
If you die to a Hawkeye, and then you look at the kill cam, and he was literally just...
Look...
Just, you know, doing simple geometry in his head.
And then...
Yeah.
Like, he's like calculating the angles, and like, algebra equations, and physics, and it was just right here.
And...
It was...
Right here.
Looking sharp.
If I die to something like that...
I think he deserves that kill.
Because...
He...
Clearly...
I feel like he deserves it, you know?
Like, he worked so hard for that kill.
If he...
He got...
I got trigonometry or some shit.
Like, he deserves it at that point.
If he can do all that.
Uh...
Pro to the math.
I'm just out here playing the game, and he's doing his math final right now.
Uh...
He's just out here doing his math final.
This is three shots.
So you can see, like...
Oh yeah, I forgot to...
Let me...
I just realized something.
I forgot to do something.
I forgot to show something important.
Which is...
He he ha ha.
This...
Goodbye, Jeff.
I'm more important than you.
And I'll guess this too.
I...
Alright.
But yes.
Not that much.
To be fair, it doesn't really matter when I can do this.
Okay, it might not look impressive.
But imagine there's three of them.
You don't have to imagine right now.
Imagine you're healing your teammates.
You know?
They're in front of you.
And you're healing your teammates.
and you can also damage them?
In a Braum fight?
That's pretty convenient.
In my opinion.
Like...
Of course.
They are all just bunched up together?
And you can just do that?
I mean, that seems very convenient right there.
When they all get bunched up.
You think a tank is going to save you?
It doesn't matter.
Tanks, yeah, but then like, I can damage as well for my left click.
That's right.
A tank is not going to save you now.
Yeah, it's basically a blameter.
Alright, what else do you guys want to see, guys?
What else do you guys want to see?
That's on Ultron?
I think a lot of people are going to play Ultron, like, as a DPS.
But if he actually is going to be healing, he has to play with his team.
He has to play with his team.
Oh, yeah.
Let me show you guys the... I'll show you guys.
The... Here, there's the blade.
Alright, so apparently what I read about... Alright, let me get on Star-Lord.
What I read about Star-Lord.
Weeeeee.
Alright, so this used to be... From what I remember, it was 30, right?
This used to be his old Ult range.
You can be here.
It can be here, and then that was as far as you can go.
You can now do this Ult all the way here.
So let me get Ult real fast.
Actually, no.
Let me just do no cooldown.
What am I doing?
Alright.
I can be here.
Yeah, this is as far as we can do it.
So now it's 40.
In the past, it's 30.
Now it's at 40.
Now my leg.
Just Luna Ult forehead.
What do you mean?
Just Luna Ult.
Yeah.
So...
So that's basically his new Ult form.
What else?
What else do you guys want to see?
Guys, is there anything else?
I'm tired of being the tickle monster.
As a sword port main?
No.
Be a tickle monster forever.
I don't care about your opinions.
Alright.
Let's see.
I don't know.
I know like this changed.
I don't really know.
I don't play sword.
So I don't know.
You guys might understand what he is.
You guys might understand.
This is the new thing.
The right click.
The right click is different from what I know.
But I don't know actually what is actually different.
But yeah.
The right click is...
This is what they added.
Yeah.
It doesn't cost resources.
But the cooldown.
As you guys can see.
Is...
Five seconds.
It's five seconds instead.
Sorry.
Thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Angry Kid and Robotic.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Um.
Alright.
What other stuff did they do?
Uh...
Let's see.
What other stuff can I show you guys?
Uh...
Oh yeah.
For those who didn't see Ultron.
This is the new skin by the way.
Luna...
Luna has nothing new.
Is there...
I...
I don't think Luna...
They didn't...
They didn't change Luna.
She feels the same for me.
I think she feels the same.
I think it's just...
Maybe damage and heals?
But...
I don't...
Find her...
Much different.
Um...
The freeze?
I think the freeze is mostly...
Yeah.
I feel like...
I feel like Luna doesn't feel that different from...
From how I usually play her.
No.
She...
275 HP just feels the same.
Oh, she gets freeze from...
Oh, okay.
I see it now.
So, you just have to hit your freezes.
By the way, it's been a while since I played Luna.
So, like...
This is gonna be interesting.
But I wanna play Jeff, though.
I wanna...
Jeff seems so fun.
Not gonna lie.
I...
I swear I wanna play Jeff.
He seems...
He seems so fun.
If I get a Storm, I'll play...
Um...
I'll play Jeff.
Because I think she'll...
Yummy Yummy will only...
Be fun.
Um...
Only...
Will only be fun when I have a Storm.
Because I can be a Jeffnado.
But yeah.
I get a shield.
I think that's her only difference, right?
She gets a shield.
From her freezes.
Yeah.
That's a lot.
From 275 to 325.
Play Jeff for the funny.
But if I get a Hawkeye, I'll play Luna.
I'll play Luna if I get a Hawkeye.
Because I think Necrose is gonna wanna play Ultron.
I'm pretty sure.
But I wanna play Ultron too.
We'll swap between.
Yeah, Necrose is gonna be on my team and he's on support duty apparently.
I don't know if that was his choice.
Or...
I don't know.
I don't know if that's his choice to play...
To wanna be a support player for the team thing.
Cause on the thing, he like...
He wrote himself as support.
So I don't know.
I...
But yeah, I can show you guys Ultron again.
So, for those who didn't know...
Watch this.
This is my favorite part when I show Ultron to people.
And then people...
I'd be like, hee hee, that's funny.
And then everybody would be like, that's not funny.
But I'm like...
Oh, wait.
Here.
This is a better guide on how far his range is.
Uh...
Let me...
Here.
I'll show you guys a better demonstration.
Alright.
You see that guy?
Watch me slowly back out.
You see him?
I'm gonna slowly back out now.
You see that?
You see how I'm slowly backing out?
You see...
You see that?
Whoa!
Why is this so far?
I'm still so far away!
Whoa!
And now let me kill that one guy.
Wait, where is he?
Let me kill him too.
Let me kill this guy too.
Whoa!
That's pretty silly.
I killed him too.
What?
Now...
Okay.
So this is his team up.
Oh, wait.
I killed him.
Sorry.
He...
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Alright.
So you're coming back from spawn and you're like, Oh no!
My teammates!
Don't worry!
I'll heal you.
I can damage him too.
I can damage him too if I want to.
There we go.
So you can literally be like...
You're like dead on spawn and then you're all the way from spawn and you're like, Don't worry!
I sh...
Oh, he's dead.
Give me a sec.
Don't worry!
I'll heal you this time.
And then...
You save the game.
You're a hero.
Congratulations.
You're a hero now.
Yippee!
Yeah, that's my favorite part of the show.
Show people.
Blah.
And then everyone clapped.
Those beings appear to be...
Yeah, without the team up, this is his only heals.
And the right click.
It's this and the right click.
But there's a range to the drones.
If you guys didn't want to hear earlier, this is the range.
It's right here, I think.
No, it's...
There you go.
That's the range.
So the moment you're, like, this far away from the drone, it despawns.
So you have to...
You have to be close to your team and you want to use...
This is literally your only heals, by the way.
There's no other way to heal your team.
Because your...
Your left click is just to fight.
Your left click...
Your left click is just to be like...
Pew pew!
I have to learn how to do the diamond too.
This sucks.
I don't play support...
I don't play support flyers.
Because this is the first support flyer.
So I have to learn how to do this.
When I'm playing.
So it's harder to hit me.
Oh my god.
Because you can't...
You can't WA spam.
You have to do this.
You have to fly in a...
God damn diamond shape.
Stupid fucking diamond flying.
Oh yeah.
Don't worry.
I'll show you guys.
I keep forgetting that you don't have to go to spawn.
How do you use emotes?
I proudly wear the X.
That's right.
Make it.
Oh wait.
Luna Snow.
That's...
That's right, Luna.
That's right.
Dance, Luna.
Dance!
Dance, Luna!
No!
Hahaha!
Is it time now?
I thought it was at 3.
Is it time?
Dance for me, Luna!
Okay.
Let me see.
Let me check Discord.
I don't know if it's time yet.
It's not time.
Yeah.
Um...
No.
We have 10 more minutes.
Yeah.
Uh...
It starts at...
Um...
2.50.
But yeah.
I love this.
Emote.
This is...
This would be my only emote that I ever buy.
And actually, no.
The Venom one too.
But I didn't buy that one.
I...
Hahaha!
Dance!
Yes!
Wait.
You're too far away.
Wait, actually.
I'll do something even better.
Dance, Venom!
Hahaha!
Yes!
Dance for your queen!
Dance!
Shake it for me!
Haha!
Were there any Groot changes?
Yes.
He's dead.
Goodbye, Groot.
Yippee!
I don't even need to show Groot.
He's nerfed.
Haha!
Don't even try playing Groot.
He's just dead.
You know why?
Let me show you why.
I just have to pick this guy.
A blunt instrument.
He...
Watch this.
Goodbye.
Hahahaha!
So I don't even need to try him.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Groot.
Hahahaha!
Just pick Punisher.
Just pick Punisher, that's all you have to do.
Cause they buffed...
They buffed Punisher's...
Okay.
This is what it's like with...
No...
I also didn't have to reload.
This was like...
I still killed him.
I didn't even have to reload.
I don't even have to reload, guys.
I still killed him.
In one mag.
And then...
There you go.
Alright.
There.
So that's why...
That's why I don't even need to show any...
Show Groot for you guys.
Cause...
Trees are gone now.
Team Trees?
More like...
Team Fire.
Hahahaha!
Now, uh...
They buffed Punisher's damage.
And they nerfed...
Groot's, uh...
They nerfed Groot's cooldowns.
So like...
It's not...
He's not his cooldown...
It takes longer to build up his...
Walls and stuff like that.
Um...
Yay!
Deforestation!
Hehehehe!
And then Punisher is obviously like...
Super strong against Groot now.
Um...
But they nerfed the...
They...
They got rid of...
Like they made the cooldown longer.
Which is great!
I hate...
I hated that.
Hahahaha!
Uh...
Um...
I can't wait to play Jeff, guys.
Wahaaaah!
Hahahaha!
That's my favorite!
Wahaaaah!
Hahahaha!
Yay!
I can finally, finally, because I don't know how to play DPS Jeff.
I have no idea how to play DPS Jeff because like I'm way too much of a support player.
I just want to save my team instead of trying to flank.
That's too much pressure for me.
You want to see the Jeffnado again?
Alright.
So the greatest part about Jeffnado is that you can eat them and then... Oh wait, I forgot to... You can eat them and then... Let me restart that.
I'll restart.
Okay, so the best part is that you can eat them and then they can't kill you because you can just be protected by the storm mineral.
So I can be like this.
I'm trying to swim away.
I'll be like, save me!
And then... He's dead.
He's dead.
And anybody that gets sucked up in a Jeffnado, um... Gets eaten by me.
So you can see that he disappeared.
It's because he got eaten by me.
So I can be like, um... And then, save me Storm!
And then Storm can just pick me up and then take me away.
Yeah.
So he can just... And then he'll just take me away and then I'll be safe.
So it guarantees kills.
So, like, you don't have to run away right now anymore.
No, so, like, you don't have to jump off the edge.
You can just be like, pick me up, mom!
Pick me up!
So you don't have to be like, oh, where's the edge?
Where's the edge?
And then, like, spit them out.
You just be like, mom!
Mom, pick me up!
And then Storm comes in and be like... Because I can be like, oh my god, he's gonna kill me!
And then, I'm like, I'm safe now.
Yay!
This is the second guy, by the way.
Because the first guy died.
The first guy died.
So, uh...
Yippee!
So, if you're, like, wondering, the first guy I picked... The guy I picked up died, like, in, like, three to four seconds in the Storm all.
Because when I... Whoever I...
Picked up... Okay, so...
Here's the interesting part.
Alright, let's see.
I'll pick him up.
And then...
I go, like, here.
And then I can extend my ult.
And Storm extends her ult, too.
Can you see?
It went six seconds.
So, whenever I go to Storm...
So, I could have the... I could have the people in my belly...
For almost the entire duration of my own ult.
But the moment I pick... Go into the Storm...
It extends the ult even longer.
Because it gives a plus six seconds extension.
So...
That's why I was like, ooh.
That's silly.
That's...
It's pretty silly, guys.
But I still think this is the silliest.
This is the silliest for me.
My years away from the Avengers...
Taught me how much they meant to me.
Eee.
Yay!
God, no.
Ice arrow unleashed!
Yay!
Wait, what if I...
Calculate this?
Okay.
Okay, it's like here.
I hit him?
I can't tell.
Can I calculate this?
Wait, that's not how arrows work.
Yeah, but they're magic arrows.
They're magic arrows.
Bro, I want to see a montage of these kills.
I...
I want to see all the montages of this.
Hawkeye technically isn't using the magic.
The arrows itself is the magic.
Do not encourage them.
Yippee!
Yeah, this...
I think montages are gonna look so sick though.
All right.
But if you guys want to check out the game...
The pad...
The official update comes out on May 30th.
So yeah, you click on the link.
You can check out the...
You can check out the newest updates on May 30th, guys.
Just remember, it's free to play.
I think it's almost time.
Let me double check.
Um...
Oh!
We gotta join Discord.
All right.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm gonna head over to the Discord.
That's a lie.
Not everybody's here yet.
Sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I was just making a joke.
The staff member was like, Everyone's in Team B.
Sorry, I didn't...
I was joking.
JK, JK.
It was like my intrusive thoughts.
I love Marvel rivals.
Heads up, bad guys.
Oh, hello, hello.
Eh.
Yup, yup, yup.
Ooh!
Let's go!
My boys!
I need a...
Look at those subs.
Oh, wait, I gotta...
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Guys, I gotta reset my Discord.
Give me a sec.
I need to do the push to talk.
So rich and generated.
Um, why is this like such a specific amount?
Wait, we can take over the directory here, guys.
Oh, no, no, no, you're sharing chats.
Oh, sharing chats!
My chat are like polar opposite.
I've never shared chats before.
Yeah, I feel like...
Yeah, this is like mixing fire and water.
It's gotta be good.
We can...
Um, no, I'm assuming it's gonna be a contrast.
Which one's mine?
I can tell which one's gonna be my chat.
I...
Oh, you think so?
Uh...
I don't know.
My chat is kind of like very overwhelming.
Why are you so ashamed of your chat, Necros?
Your chat is cool.
Wait, okay.
I need to like...
I need to restart my Discord.
Do you think this is readable?
They don't just seem like...
Oh, man.
Like, I'm just reading all my Discord stuff.
It's not readable anyway.
That's true.
It's too many people.
Oh, my God.
Sound...
Sound team.
Wait, what are we missing right now?
DM me...
DM me to tell me who I need to raise up and who I don't.
But don't worry.
I'm setting up the stuff now.
Yeah, this is needed right now.
Where is this?
Where is the server even called?
I don't even remember.
I got to find this server too.
What is this server called?
Oh, my God.
Where is it?
I cannot read any of that.
How many messages do you read like a day?
I don't know.
It isn't usually this fast.
It's pretty fast.
But it isn't this fast.
I'm not doing this.
All right, there you go.
I told you.
I told you it's not readable.
That was overwhelming.
There you go.
Yeah.
Now you see the HP in there.
It's just like a whole bunch of sabow, sabow, thighs, thighs.
I don't know.
Okay, you guys don't need to see my HP.
It's because it's all the bop, right?
Yeah, it's the viewbot.
It's the viewbot.
Yo, press one if you're a viewbot.
Press one.
Okay.
One.
I'm already typing one.
Okay, bring necros down.
Okay.
I'm just fixing the sound, guys.
Oh, my God.
Bring necros down.
Okay, I brought him down.
Don't worry, sound team is...
What are you talking about over here?
Sound team is helping me right now.
Why are we doing one?
Oh, my God.
I was too busy.
I don't know why I was pressing one.
People are excited.
They're so excited about this.
I'm amped.
Yeah.
Hi, Steven.
I gotta restart my Discord.
I'll be right back.
All right.
Yeah, go ahead.
Wait, Andrew has 150...
All right, let me restart my Discord.
I need to do admin mode, because I need to push to mute.
All right, here we go.
All right.
I don't know.
I don't even know what was going on.
Okay, mute button.
Where the heck is my mute button?
Sorry, guys.
I gotta figure all of this out.
All right.
We got company.
What?
What's that?
Who said that?
Oh, wait.
I was like, who said that?
That scared me.
Okay.
See, add a key button.
Wait, does Hawkeye say that?
I was like, who's that?
Who's that freak?
I'll use V.
Is V anything on Rivals?
I don't know.
Let's see.
I gotta make sure I don't actually press anything.
Is V anything on Rivals, guys?
Melee?
Okay, I re-binded that.
All right.
My mute, push to mute would be V then.
All right, nice.
All right, we're all good to go.
Uh, I could run the Ultron for us.
Hey, I'm back.
Honestly, honestly, they wanted me...
I'll do the first game and then, uh, Doki, because we're supposed to play Strata, just then you can try it if you want.
All right, yeah, yeah.
I'll do it after you, Necros.
I'll play Jeff first, then.
Jeff seems fun.
Wait, we need to do the Jeff Storm team up.
That shit was so funny.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because it adds plus six seconds to the storm mode.
And then whoever I eat, whoever I eat gets the storm damage when I'm in it.
Am I in this cold?
Sorry, or am I in all the cold?
Yeah, you're in this one.
You're with us, you're with us.
This is our team.
Hey, guys, how you doing?
I'm amazing.
Hey, where's the custom room for it?
Can you just join us, Doki?
Oh, yeah.
It's a custom game.
It's like the season 2.5 starts on May 30th room.
That one.
A what?
Season 2.5 starts on May 30th.
Wait, I'm not even the last person.
Who are you waiting for?
Rage, I think.
Not last.
Wait, we lost your chat, Nekros.
Are we all already added as friends on these accounts?
You want them back?
Yeah, we can run it.
All right, Nekros, we're going to need you to come back.
Huh?
What do you mean, come back?
Oh, you want my chat?
Yeah, you know what?
What do you mean?
You just said you didn't want it.
You just kicked it.
No, I just need a little break.
I just need a little break.
You need a little break?
All right, I'm going to turn down Nekros a little bit more.
Ease into it, bro.
All right, let me know if everything is good.
Enjoy.
All right, I'm here for Jeff now.
By the way, I don't play Jeff, but it's good.
Are we added as friends already?
Or do we want to close the mattress home?
I am not a Jeff there, but it's going to be an example.
Yeah, an experience.
But like, it seems fun.
Literally, I played every character but Jeff.
Jeff was like the old because he was like DPS Jeff.
I was like, blanking Jeff is too much effort.
Oh, everyone.
Discord is too loud.
I'll turn it down a little.
Okay, okay.
Let me know if it's better.
Who's on the other team?
That's comp.
Who's comp on the other team?
Yeah, yeah.
They said they won quick match.
They don't want comp.
All right, guys.
All right.
AJ.
Let me know if it's better.
I lowered the Discord volume too.
You ready?
Nah, not at all, man.
I'm rusty, bro.
I'm not going to lie.
What's the last time you played?
Weeks ago, bro.
Good luck.
I'm a diamond solo queue, which means I'm essentially a Celestial, bro.
If you think about it.
Facts.
Pretty much.
That's how that works.
Wait.
Who's on the other team that we should be worried about?
Um, almost all of them.
Nobody.
So who's their best player?
Okay, good.
Majority of them are one above all except for Lydia.
Wait.
It's okay.
You have four one above all's, you have four one above all's, it's okay.
Okay, we have four one above all's.
They got what, five?
Yeah, we have two rank ones, so yeah, better.
So what does everybody here play?
Like, what's y'all roles?
Let's get to know the team a little bit, huh?
Guru is tank.
I'm DPS, pref.
Play, like, Punisher, Hawkeye.
My, like, two mains, but I can really play anything, to be honest.
Yeah, same.
I don't mind flexing.
Yo, let's start it up, shall we?
Yeah, I heard Nekos is, like, the best support player.
Yeah, yeah, I'm supposed to be playing support, yeah.
But, I mean, I don't mind.
If someone else wants to try Ultron, I'm down to, like, run something else.
It's not a problem.
Harry, no, no, you go crazy, bro.
I saw your support, man.
You made it all the way to the level.
You proved them all wrong.
Yeah, I proved myself.
They said I couldn't do it.
I did it.
You did it, man.
I watched your stream, because you're the only one that streamed at 8 a.m.
Yeah, I mean, I'm from EU, so yeah, I'm up, like, kind of, like, right now.
All right, Max Games are ready.
I, like, remember when I'm...
Okay, they're ready.
All right, I'm sorry.
When I'm muted and when I'm not, because that's awkward when I'm...
Let's get it.
You know, there's a lot on the line here, guys.
Okay.
100k tournament here.
Oh, and new map.
Yeah, new map, new map.
I need to bring people up a little bit.
Bring...
Gale up a little bit.
And Rage...
That's my guy.
...down.
And then Gale a little up.
I hope everything's better now.
All right.
You...
Oh.
Chip time!
Stop laughing at me.
Why are you guys laughing?
Oh, you want me to do the storm thing, Doki?
Or do you want to do the Hawkeye and...
Oh.
I'm down for whatever.
Which one are you?
If we got the team up.
Let's...
Let's hit...
Let's hit the team up.
All right.
Let's do the storm Jeff after.
Oh, yeah.
The shooting through walls?
That's crazy.
Yeah.
It's insane.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
I can't take this.
Let's see what the door look like.
How do I get...
Oh, is that the door?
Actually didn't look at...
Oh, the emote!
That's cute.
Right through...
The G thing.
But...
I can't go to the portal.
Like the moon.
I figured it out.
Oh, they have Penny.
They have Penny.
I hear Penny setting up.
Here comes.
Okay.
Lock in team.
There's a Penny nest right outside of the door.
There's a lot on the line here, guys.
I'm scared.
Lock in.
Let's go!
What is that?
I thought I was in group.
What the hell is that?
What is that?
Oh, he's a part of the map, I think.
Oh, he's the thing.
He's the...
Oh!
That was you!
Wait, he's won.
Someone's won.
I froze him?
That is sick.
Why is this guy on Venom?
This guy's playing strong.
Wow!
He's try hiding.
Yeah, real.
Oh, wait.
They're gonna do the Jeff...
The Jeff Nato team up.
I could hit...
I could...
How do you reload?
I froze Ultron.
Ultron won?
GG.
Oh!
No, I'm done.
Alright.
That was chip damage.
Dunn's looking for dive.
Alright, we're good.
Oh, he's low.
I'm safe.
Let us free low.
If you're playing Venom, like...
I don't know.
I'm trying to play Wolverine.
He's tough.
I mean, go for it.
Oh, they have a penny thing here.
Hey, keep putting wheels.
I got it.
Already locking the Wolverine.
I love it.
If he's playing Venom, like...
I mean, they're trying the new team up with Jeff, so I think he...
Alright.
5-0.
He's got it.
Alright.
Not fighting pennies.
Oh, he's nice.
Hey, Ultron is crushing me right now.
I got him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Where are they?
Well played.
This map is so confusing.
It was their Ultron.
Okay, bro.
It's nice.
I'm Ultron.
Oh, our crew is so far up.
One way on us.
That's good.
I got him.
I'm Ultron as well.
Three, two, one.
Rocket.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Yummy, yummy.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
We can't take you over.
To Jeffnado.
Oh, my God.
We're helping.
I got him.
We're up one, guys.
Over.
I'm about to die.
Reloading?
Oh, the Ultron's lost.
I got you, I got you.
Oh, thanks, guys.
Appreciate it.
I'm good.
How you feeling, AJ?
I'm good, I'm good.
Hey, Penny go.
Where did Penny go?
It's okay.
Yo!
How the Penny just teleported?
That's crazy.
Yeah, he's teleported.
He's lagging.
Hit him, Rage!
Come on.
Nice.
Thanks for the shield.
Oh, we did it.
First point.
I like that.
I like that, bro.
Nice captain.
Let's go.
Yeah!
I like that out of you.
Okay.
I love this map.
That's right.
That's kind of cool.
This map is actually pretty cool.
I like this map too.
I'm pushing the cart right now.
I'll turn down.
So you have, like, Ultron heals.
You got that objective.
Alright, you got Ultron heals.
There might not be a lot of heals.
Yeah.
I'm trying to keep you alive.
I'm still just killin'.
I gotta miss.
Oh my god.
Penny is right there, bro.
Kidnap this controller.
Penny is still right in this corner.
Penny's right in this corner.
What do we do about that?
I don't know, bro.
That's a good little spot.
Still walk through the right.
That's a good little spot, bro.
Can I get a couple of heals, pretty please?
Bro, chat, what do you do?
Oh yeah, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, yeah.
Where is he?
Oh, you might try to ult you.
Oh, I might be dead here.
I'm dead here.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good, yeah.
Thank you.
Wait, he can't swing out.
Yeah, I'm trying, I'm trying.
Nice, thank you.
You keep everyone else alive.
Yeah, yeah.
Interesting map.
I have ult here.
And I'm low.
Nice.
Oh, I froze someone in the back.
Oh my God.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
It's Yogi Yogi time.
I had ult.
He tried to steal the ult.
Bro, he literally went right for me.
They're gonna eat you though.
Get you killed.
You're gonna die in the ult.
Do I get special?
Yo, that's insane.
I was alone.
I can't do anything about it.
It grabbed all of us.
Holy shit.
I'm trying to keep you alive.
I can't.
I'm trying.
It actually grabbed all of us in it.
That's insane.
I was alone.
Bro.
That's cool.
That's really powerful.
Oh, shoot.
It's a storm.
Alright.
It's actually moving.
Locky.
God.
Alright, push him down.
You guys don't have a lot of heals.
I'll try an ult.
Yeah, we're good.
Oh, yeah, we're good.
Okay, we're good.
Oh, hell.
Wait, there's two penny mines now?
Yeah, yeah.
If you have a rocket.
You guys need to get down from there.
Get down from there.
It's, uh, team up.
I got my ult now.
Uh, yeah.
I'm coming over.
You got a lot of heals.
No way I get ult in here, huh?
But have you built ultrots really fast, Necroz?
On ultrots?
Uh, it builds a pretty, yeah, pretty fast.
Yeah, you guys are much faster than Luna.
Nice.
I froze him.
Got him.
Oh my god, he just exploded.
Nice.
Yeah.
You guys okay back there?
Where are you guys going back there?
Don't run from me, boy.
Why are you killing?
I yoinked that final kill.
Nice.
So this is the next checkpoint.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What was that again?
What was that about?
Wait, get the rocket.
Get the rocket.
Where is she?
I got you.
Oh, that's a naughty.
That's fine.
The spawn is right there.
It's like... Oh, no, no, no.
There's like two of the flies.
There's a lot of verticality.
I'm back in the fight.
How do I kill this?
All that matters.
Oh, hell no.
I'm trying to get... Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
I'm going to spawn.
Get back to spawn, back to spawn, back to spawn.
Oh, he's on me.
I'm safe.
The hell is this chat?
I feel like Storm is exclusively focusing on me, bro.
He's your threat.
You're too scary.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm so scary.
Oh, yeah.
You're doing too good.
We gotta get you out.
Oh, hell no.
Okay, I'm on, I'm on.
I'm on.
I'm shooting Emma.
I'm dead.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck is he trying to do?
I think they messed up.
Wait, we can kill Venom.
Oh, we got Venom.
We have Ultron ult after.
How is he still alive?
Yeah, you build it really.
Where is our spawn?
Yeah, you get it like...
We hit this thing so much.
Oh my god.
Where's...
That little ratat.
Finally, I hit it.
Oh, shit.
I hear somebody right behind me.
You just hit me.
What the fuck?
Someone is among me right now.
Hey, I'm ulting.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Ulting back me there, bro.
I'm backing up.
Very slowly.
Goodbye.
Oh, trying to heal you guys.
Trying to heal you guys.
Well, I fought, man.
That's on me.
We're good.
Oh, I got you.
Alright.
I'll give you Snowflake, girl.
We almost got it, though.
We're right there.
It's the last push.
Oh, shit.
I'm away.
Oh!
They're doing it.
Oh, no.
Did you have low?
He ate only me.
Goodbye!
He ate me, too.
I made me dead.
Oh, yeah.
We're good.
The...
...stores behind me.
Yeah, you guys have low heals.
They're shooting...
Yeah.
I'm dead.
No, no, no, no.
Storm1Hmae.
Oh, y'all getting cooked up.
Oh, my God.
I don't even know...
It's a bit tough.
When Luna dies, you have really low heals.
Yeah.
I think Ultron is like more like a...
Where the hell is Mag teleporting to?
I'm dead.
No, wait.
Keep backing up.
You can live...
Oh, never mind.
I lied.
Guys, two minutes.
Lock it on in.
We can try the Jeff Storm combo.
True, true, true, true.
Look at B got to win this.
I'm looking at him.
You got my ult?
Ultron won.
I see it.
Yeah, you can tell I'm rusty.
Oh, my God!
Oh!
I tried to save you!
That's a pack.
This is my shield Ultron!
Oh my God, bro.
Jesus, I'm just gonna ult here.
Alright, we brawl.
We're brawling.
Okay, I'm dead.
Ultron, ult!
Oh, I'm alive.
I leave.
Uh-oh.
I'm going through a lot of emotions.
Oh!
Actually managed to keep you through it.
I'm back it out.
I'm alive, though.
Yeah, you're on.
Boger, why don't you be on the right?
You getting heals?
You still half?
Oh, no.
I'm not peeking them.
No, I'm fine.
Got you.
They're pushing me here.
Yeah, they're pushing me, too.
I'm trying to keep your left.
I'm dead.
Yeah, I can't.
Yeah, they're chasing me.
All right, we're going to need a storm for the jets.
Oh, jets, argola.
Do we even have time now?
Yep.
Boger's on the left.
He's up to no good.
Yeah, he's like playing that room.
Enough side.
All right.
There's nobody in there.
I hear... I hear someone behind me.
Yeah, yeah.
No, there is Nemo.
I'm shielding you're fine, I think.
I think he's on too, but my teammates are not fine.
I've been so outplayed, bro.
Wait, wait, Mike can die in there.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
He bubbled himself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's one.
I'm trying to escape you.
He's one of me.
Oh, they're doing the combo.
They're doing the combo.
I got it.
Goodbye, everyone.
Not so good.
Oh, my God.
Now, that combo is so OP.
No, that's the Jeff Storm thing.
Yeah.
I can't really touch.
No.
Yeah, no, that is nuts.
We got lucky.
All good.
Yeah, they went Jeff.
They went, uh, Jeff Storm.
They unfortunately just had Jeff Storm.
Guys, why did we not ban...
Yeah.
Bad draft.
Yeah, bad banline, guys.
Bad banline.
I'll swap sides so we, uh, defend now.
Actually, can I?
Oh, team swap, yeah.
I think I can probably start again, right?
Wait, so anyone know how long we're playing?
Is it like one hour or, uh...
Um, it's one hour.
But then we can play longer if we want.
Okay.
Yes.
All right.
So does anyone want to try Ultron?
I want to Jeff.
I want to try Jeff.
I can Ultron if you want.
That's fun.
I want to do Jeff.
Off to you.
And then...
Someone can go Storm.
Google can Storm, yeah?
Sure, sure, sure.
I can do Storm.
You want to do Storm here?
I think...
Maybe you can do Tag.
No, no, no.
It's all you.
That's fun, though.
That is...
That...
The Jeff...
The Jeffnado is scary.
The...
The Jeffnado is actually so scary.
Guys.
It was like...
Flyer comp.
It was literally like...
They literally win because of the Jeffnado.
Oh, we're trying to Storm, Jeff?
Ultron either.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's our turn.
Fire, fire, fire.
Yeah.
I think I have like less than an hour play time on Jeff.
Oh, okay.
I mean...
Hey, man.
Just do your best, you know?
It's okay.
I got this.
How hard can it be?
Can't be that hard.
Three...
Two...
One...
Oh.
Just here.
Like down here, I think.
Under this bridge.
Oh, my God.
Where am I getting hit from?
I'm behind a little bit, guys.
Late to work.
I don't know where I'm getting hit from.
Where's my Groot?
New map.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
The Groot's here.
Holy shit.
There's someone to the top.
Above us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Punisher 1.
Nice.
Oh, God.
Jesus.
Didn't I?
Holy smokes.
All the flying characters.
Yeah, they got a lot of fire.
Yeah.
Oh, I can't Q2 up.
Oh, my God.
That's why he does.
That's why I'm not coming from.
You're taking so much damage.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I'm just healing.
Oh, my God.
I just...
What is that?
I can't stop healing.
They got a lot of memes.
A lot of memes.
What do we do?
Wait, wait, wait.
Nah, nah, nah.
Yo, wait, wait.
We just triggered.
Alright.
Can we just not, like, give a little more?
I can touch, maybe?
I'm on?
I can't even DPS.
I'm just kidding.
Jesus Christ.
Goodbye, everybody.
I'm trying.
We are just getting melted.
Guys, Team B needs a victory here.
We can't be letting this happen.
I'm a lost in this map.
I don't know where...
I don't know where I'm going, either.
There's so many halls and corridors.
Yeah, I'm a little lost.
They're amazing.
Okay.
Alright, Nekros, you have your all, Nekros.
I got your drone, Nekros.
Oh, he just knew, he knew, he knew, he knew.
Where the fuck did he just...
Sorry, guys.
I don't know where I am.
I don't know where I am, either.
Oh my gosh.
I think.
I got my ult.
Do you want a combo?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm respawning, I'm respawning.
I do an ult on the ult.
This is a tough.
I'm just cooked, I'm just cooked.
I don't know.
Nightline.
Just go ahead, just throw it through.
Send it, send it, send it.
I need a five from where they are.
There you are.
Oh, we're running.
I think we're cooked.
What?
Oh my god, he ulted me there.
He just destroyed me with Punisher ult.
Nooo.
I couldn't get picked up.
I'm so sad.
Yeah, they just popped the Punisher ult.
Yeah, we got locked in here, bro.
That's what's happening.
This map is...
I'm all of you on this, nigga.
What's up?
I think we're just trying to figure out like...
Run me the ones.
Run the ones.
What's up?
We don't know where we are.
I'm so confused.
Yeah.
He's not just sold.
Oh my god, bro.
Shroud, just do it, bro.
I think I just need to be picked up by you.
Get this, Shroud, just...
You get over there?
Agent?
Me and Shroud are kicking right now.
Wait, where is everybody?
There's only four of us.
Where's the other two?
Yo, Agent.
Yeah.
What's the status over there, bro?
Where's...
Where's the...
Aw, they're doing a streamer thing.
Nah, they're doing weird stuff.
They're doing a streamer thing.
What are they doing?
What's happening?
They missed, they missed, they missed.
They missed.
I got my first kill.
Let's go.
One of minutes.
Oh my god, guys, we did it.
We won our first team fight.
I'm proud of y'all.
Love you.
Wait, I made one.
Behind us, behind us.
There's a furniture behind.
Yeah, the spawn is right there.
Oh, what the heck?
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah, we're in their spawn, guys.
Cap can die.
Yeah.
Owned.
Oh, no.
I might be dead.
They spawn here.
I'm good.
Yeah.
I don't know where they spawn right now.
Oh, these lasers!
A lot of lasers.
I'm good.
Yeah, I just got the combo.
Alright.
I'm a rat.
I'm gonna spawn, GG.
Oh, I don't have heal.
I have to heal those.
Nice.
Go ahead, go ahead.
Wait, there's a Punisher behind us.
No, no, no, no, no.
I don't see the Punisher.
He's at the height.
Any heals?
Bro.
I'm coming back now.
Yeah.
Oh, goodbye, Aegid.
Goodbye.
Bro.
I didn't know that could happen.
There's a cliff on this map.
There's a cliff on this map?
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Oh, there's all these lasers.
There's so many lasers.
Oh, where am I?
Oh, my God.
There you go.
I got you again.
Agent, how you feeling, Agent?
Better not I'm on Hulk, man.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, I have to reload.
All good.
I set my ult here.
Watch that Iron Man ult.
You fucker.
Oh, yeah.
That's Iron Man ult.
What does this do?
What does this take me?
Alright, let's do the combo this time for sure.
Alright, we have like the sixth ult.
Let's just use everything.
Knead.
Oh my God.
Oh, my God.
Tick me up, pick me up, pick me up, pick me up.
Oh, no.
He's here.
Oh!
Thank you.
Heavy pan.
He's on.
He's Débuked, he's on.
Oh, no.
We're dead.
So many lasers.
It's okay.
He's so, don't kill him.
PattonATTÄ±yorumix.
He's so low.
I got you.
He's go too low.
Oh, Usain with the heals!
I got you over there.
Hit him.
Did you get him?
Oh, he's one!
I got him!
Wait, there's someone behind us.
I think it's the Punisher.
Oh, no, it's Captain America.
Cap, Cap, Cap.
Cap one, Cap one.
Where are you spawning?
Like, here.
Oh, I went to their spawn.
Portal, portal, portal, portal, portal.
Oh, he might do a streamer clip again.
He's gonna set up an Iron Man ult.
Or something.
They're doing something.
They're thinking.
What are they doing back here?
There it is!
I do it!
Wait, do it!
They didn't show on my screen!
I do it!
They popped out.
They're over here.
They do it!
Oh, the fuck is on me!
I got you!
Oh, thank you!
Oh, he caught everyone!
Oh,
he's so low!
Oh, he's so low!
Please!
It's so crazy!
I don't know where anything is!
I have ult here.
Okay.
Make it happen.
Whoever this strange is, I hate him.
Yo, all these lasers, bro!
I tried, bro.
Get the freak away from me, bro!
Oh, I couldn't!
I'm celebrating the fuck out.
I'm dead.
Oh, far.
We almost had the combo.
Wait, can we hit the point?
Oh!
No!
So, I forgot about that.
You forgot about that.
Damn it.
I think we're just very last.
We had.
Let's diagnose what went wrong there, guys.
Um...
Oh, we lost.
Wait, the first two points, we had no idea where we were.
We were, like...
Half of us were split up.
Yeah, we were, like, staggering.
We're slurring the map.
I'm at the punny here.
Hold on.
I'm gonna try, let's try.
What are my thoughts on Jeff?
I think, like, our team wasn't coordinated to utilize Jeff there.
Jeff worked well for the other team, only because, like, they were...
more coordinated than us.
Because they were all bunched up, boy.
We were very split up.
I was like, wait, there's four of us.
We're...
Like, at one point in the fight, I was like...
If it's this hard, then everybody's got way better.
Wait, there's four of us.
Where's the other two players?
Like...
On age's life, we win this one.
We have a tournament.
Hell no, man.
Y'all are sweaty.
It's not gonna be that hard.
It's not gonna be this hard.
Oh, hell no.
I don't even know what color that rank is.
Is it red?
I'm trying to adjust...
my volume...
real quick.
Oh, yeah.
It's red.
By the way, Black Widow has the Teemo for the Punisher.
It's pretty crazy.
You want one of us to play Black Widow?
490 gold.
It's up to you guys.
I don't really play it.
You do not want me on Widow, I think.
Just exist as a person.
Alright.
We're locking in this game.
I didn't remember like...
Oh, I'm just dead already.
my left click is not healed.
Got one.
Got two that fast.
That's crazy.
Oh, he's Thor.
Oh no, you're about to get ditched, boy.
You're about to get ditched, boy.
Oh, I don't think we have enough healing with Mantis Ultron though.
Because Ultron doesn't heal that much.
Yeah.
Ultron's heal is like really weak.
I'm not gonna lie.
Right there, it felt like the Ultron heals made the difference, man.
I can do it.
I can do Loki.
It's alright.
Alright.
Oh, you're doing...
Uh...
Okay, okay.
Okay.
All I can do is just press E.
And occasionally right click.
What did he just do to damage me that much?
Oh my god.
He actually shits my...
My bots.
Sentral's so weird.
Eh.
Wait, who's over there?
Oh, I'm gonna need health.
Rage is in there.
It's Boger.
Oh.
Boger's Rage Bating.
He's Rage Bating.
I'm cooked.
That was such a bad decision.
I got you.
I got healing.
Goodbye.
Well...
I'm back.
Bye, love.
Thank you so much for the save.
Come back.
Yeah, right.
Ultron is so fast.
So Ultron.
Oh, there.
We're...
We're running.
Not bad.
Oh, no.
Nice!
Thank you.
My hero.
There's a door over too, right?
Kill Boger.
He's won.
Oh, he's dead.
Go right, team.
Alright.
We're doing it.
Wait, Rocket is...
Rocket's here or left?
Yeah, they're healing the door.
Extaration!
Backing up a little.
Back off.
It's...
Fighter time!
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Let's slow it down.
Kill Boger.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I got res.
I got res.
Nice.
Bro, Penny is powerful.
Oh, my...
Get the...
The team up.
Nice.
I got cap.
I got C9.
Yikes.
I would never do that.
Thor half?
Thor low.
Nice.
Stop.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
I'm so not used to flying in a diamond shape.
So disorienting.
Ogre is behind.
Again?
He's trolling.
He's rage meeting.
I'm gonna chase him.
Okay.
I'll follow you.
I'll pocket you.
Okay, don't die.
I'm fine.
I'm hearing noises.
I don't know where.
You're halfway there.
You're ready for combo.
He's low.
Oh, wait.
The Ultron is also here.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna have this.
No.
That was my bad.
I'm just dead.
They're behind us.
Yeah.
Thor is low.
That's alright.
Nice.
Hey, I'm gonna be on him.
Shit.
Oh, he almost capped me.
A little too hard there.
Jeff have?
I might be.
Got his?
I mean, we're taking a payload.
They're doing whatever the hell.
Yeah, I'm just trying to make sure.
My store is okay.
Nice.
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
I healed you too.
Good one.
Maximum pulse.
Where the heck was that?
You are strong.
You are such a loser.
Oh, my God.
Rock and low.
Yeah, they are, man.
Nice.
What did he do to you?
I'm about to quit.
Sorry.
Did you hold?
Yeah.
So, again.
Again, I really remind y'all, man.
Like, it's been some weeks, bro.
What did he do to you?
I, yeah.
Hey, yeah.
No, everyone's laughing.
I see.
Okay.
It's all right.
You're here.
I just walked here.
I need the cardio, so.
Okay.
Wait, Bugger's doing weird shit.
I don't like that.
Where is Bugger?
What the fuck?
I didn't like that.
What the fuck is that?
I might need hills.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
I just realized I'm not using my crosshair.
All right.
We should have Strangel coming up soon.
But I'm tickling their eye, man.
He is not taking test.
I just realized I have been on default crosshair this entire time.
Yeah, I got default on.
Okay.
It's too easy to do it.
I forgot about that.
There's two in there.
That guy hates you, Rage.
Oh, my God.
This guy hates you, bro.
Try this half?
Oh.
Oh, what the fuck?
I got it.
Two can ult.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, we amped up.
We amped up.
Nice, nice, nice.
Guys.
Guys, we're doing it, guys.
We're doing it.
Oh, not in there.
Oh, hell no.
I think I'll be doing it.
Oh, shoot.
You're so fast.
Oh, my God.
You can just keep up with me.
I keep...
Oh, my God.
Left click not heal.
Click not heal.
Fuck.
You're welcome.
I'm not missing this dude.
I'm out of here.
Oh, my God.
The damage boost.
Oh, fuck.
That's scary.
Oh, my God.
You guys are getting bowed down.
I can't out heal that.
I don't think me and Rocket can out heal that.
Oh.
You're safe.
Don't worry.
Happy thoughts, Dale.
Happy thoughts.
Don't die.
He's low.
Slow.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'll try slow.
I'll try slow too.
Nice.
I got two.
I give you shield.
Amazing.
Oh, I'm flying up.
I'm flying up.
No, no, no, no.
You're fine.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Wait, where is he?
Where is he?
Agent.
That meant life.
I saw how I was defending that ult.
Oh, he was one.
I didn't realize there was a TP.
Iron man low.
Oh, what?
Damn Iron man old.
But I have mine, Gale.
Okay.
Yeah, we can easily walk in.
All right.
Let's get it.
Okay.
Nice.
Yo, where did you go, bro?
Okay, I got you.
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Watch this.
We did it!
We went crazy!
We went nuts!
Yes, sir!
Oh, my God.
Agent.
I like the final hits out of you.
You feel me?
I like them out of you.
We did it.
That was awesome.
Oh, my God.
I keep forgetting my shift a lot.
We try our best.
Ultron heals is not a lot, guys.
I can't heal myself on Ultron.
And, like, I have to...
This is my first time on a flyer support.
So, like...
Yeah.
I'll try to heal this.
Is anyone here, like, semi-competent at Widow?
Because...
I am not at all.
I can play it.
Alright.
No, no, but, like, we need...
No, we need...
Can someone else play Punisher, then?
Who's got the...
I want to see the Necro's Punisher.
I've never seen that ever before.
Oh, I don't know about that.
I don't know about that.
That's, like, never been whooped out ever before.
Yes, you gotta whooped out for one time.
Oh, no.
For the one time.
Okay.
Yes.
Alright, alright, I'll show you.
I'll show you.
This is great news.
Let's see.
Oh, they don't have the Rocket Punisher team up anymore.
Some hidden talents about to...
That's better hidden.
Uh...
Really, really hidden.
Super hidden.
I don't know what support to play.
We don't have any other team ups, right?
Uh...
I'll just go Jeff.
Coming in 30 seconds.
Stay strong.
Oh, wait.
Hmm...
You guys think Jeff and Ultron healing is enough?
Eh...
Like, pretty weak, right?
What is it?
Ultron and Jeff heals.
Oh...
It might be fine.
Yeah.
It might be a little weak.
If it's too weak, I'll swap.
The battle starts in five...
Four...
Three...
Two...
One...
Oh, tell me.
You're alive.
Alright.
Send up the turret.
I see.
When you're not pushing card, that's good.
We have more time to reset ourselves.
Plasma?
Oh.
Oh, we're all so slow.
Alright.
Judge.
Jury.
Execution.
Good luck, everyone.
I got one.
Oh, no.
It's like I'm being shot on the show.
I'll draw it back here.
Is that 908?
Where am I?
Good shit, good shit, good shit, good shit.
I don't even know where they are.
Where are they?
I'm just holding air.
You killed him.
Wait, Uda and I saw him.
Hello, guys.
I'm going to take a TP.
Where am I going?
I don't know.
Where are we?
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Lock it in.
I'm behind them.
It's a strat.
We're behind them.
They didn't expect it.
I didn't expect it.
The teams did it, I think.
Let's go, Agent.
Let's get up in the corner.
I got my ult.
I'm going to go crazy.
Wait, where are you guys?
How's the ult?
Oh my god.
Maybe I got you.
Oh, I don't think you got him.
Oh, no.
Oh, shit.
Agent.
GG, bro.
Yeah, I almost fucked up.
Hey, hey, they're like solo ult in me.
They must be afraid of me or something, man.
I can't fucking get out.
Fuck.
It's so weird.
How's the Teemo feel?
I like it.
It's not the greatest, but it's not terrible.
They hit a checkpoint.
Alright.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Don't go that way.
We might have more heals now.
Let's see what happened here.
What did that big burst...
What was that?
What was the big burst right there?
Oh, you were like above.
I couldn't see you.
Oh my god.
I did not see that guy.
Oh, you're safe.
Oh, I got my ult.
I got my ult.
I'm ready.
I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
Come on!
I've conored.
But doing this his way.
Oh, oh shit.
I think he is almost strong.
Yeah we gotta regroup, guys.
Yo i need...
Alright, myaaaa...
Oh no.
I do need heals too.
Oh, try no.
Oh my god, there's so many flyers now.
Yeah, they didn't even push the cart, like, at all.
Yeah.
I think there's a Widow behind, by the way.
I got the Red Beacon.
Oh, nice.
Ooh, I like that out of you.
I froze somebody.
I got it, but I'm on me.
I got you.
Okay.
I'm beaming him.
Pretty low.
What?
Ooh, the Hulk.
I like that.
Oh my god, are you okay?
I can't heal you, though, over there.
I'm so fine.
I'm dead.
I have to reload.
Sorry.
Oh, Widow is one.
Back you.
Nice heals.
Wait, then I'm gonna die here.
Oh.
Nice.
I'm dead.
Oh, it's fine.
I'm sorry.
Can I get some of that?
He's one.
Thanks for the shield.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Nice.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Yay, we're alive.
Target neutralized.
Oh my god.
I don't know if he'll be alive.
Oh.
Please.
Please, thank you.
I got my ult.
Agent.
I got you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
This is like a sniper off right now.
Oh, fuck!
How did he get there?
Jury.
Executioner!
I've still got songs to sing.
It's go time.
I have my ult, by the way.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Maybe, uh...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm leaving.
Wait!
You got one!
I thought I was the main character there.
Oh my god, he's bragging?
You better stop that vehicle!
Oh, close!
So close.
I don't know if I want to peek that.
Alright, good luck to you two.
Oh, he's won.
We went to touch point.
I'll get touch.
Who's got that?
None of us.
I don't got it.
I don't see we... none of us.
We went to touch point.
That was a little low.
Noooo...
Fucking three of them swung me on the left.
What the hell?
Going too much.
Oh!
Oh my god, Chad.
Okay, um...
Let's do a bit of a grouping.
I'm 1hp.
Group up.
Any help.
I'm sure there's one.
Wait, there's someone behind me.
Is that him behind me?
Oh, I couldn't see him.
I got you.
Reload?
What's he doing over here?
He's coming back.
Nice.
Sniper to...
Widow to left.
I need heal, so...
No, this map is so confusing, because everything's the same color.
No, like...
So, like...
It's more so of, like...
Trying to figure out...
He's so much healing.
Like, learning this map for me in my first try.
Little split.
Oh.
That was toughy.
Yeah, I mean...
I think I'm down on player.
I don't think you want me in Iron Man.
I tried.
It's kind of tough into, uh...
Two hitscans.
Especially when they happen to be, uh...
Pretty fucking good at hitscans.
And a first time in this group.
It's a bit tough.
I think you did great.
All good.
You think I did great?
I was lying.
Thank you.
Wait, did you ult?
Necros?
Yeah, yeah, I did.
I was ulting.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, one time it was a wall.
And then the other time it was...
The ground.
Oh.
It was great.
Variety, right?
I'm gonna have the Hawkeye here.
Yeah, please.
Got you.
Maybe do Luna for the team-up.
Oh, yeah, you want Luna?
And then I do Iron Fist for your team-up.
No, you do Luna, you do Luna.
Oh, I do that?
Okay.
Big team-ups, big team-ups.
I actually play this hero, so it's fine.
I don't even...
I still don't know where the portals take you.
I didn't even realize you were portals until the...
Jeff ate us.
Yeah, let's see how you use this dual chat.
Whoa, where am I?
Oh, wait, it takes me to the front.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
This is our round, guys.
Yeah, this is it.
I believe.
I don't know how many portals are around this map.
I don't know.
Oh, there's a bunch on first point and then...
I think there's none on second and there's like two on third.
Do they open like automatically or like is it time?
Yeah, yeah, they're open from the start.
Oh.
So like the one right in front of us are actually these in a flank.
Do you guys want to try it?
What if we all went through the portals?
Yeah, shit.
There's a stranger on the left side, I think.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Oh, they did the Hawkeye.
Oh, they froze all of us.
That is crazy.
I got him.
Oh, you should do it.
Nice.
Hide him through the walls as well.
Wait, there's a...
There's an ultron behind us.
I need help.
I need heals.
Thank you.
I got him.
Nice.
Got him.
Got you.
Oh.
Are you okay over there?
Yeah, I'm good.
I'm good.
Alright.
You're halfway there.
Keep going.
One.
Up, up, up, up left.
I got you.
Reload.
Oh, I need heals.
I need heals.
Thank you.
Almost there.
Oh, rock it low.
Yo.
There's a penny on the left.
Penny on the left.
Are they still in penny half?
One?
I'm cooking.
Nice.
Chat, I think I'm carrying ultron for real.
Go.
Alright.
I don't know, Chris, you have the...
Gale.
We gotta set up like a combo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta set up a combo with you and me.
Like, you shoot through the wall with your C on my ult or something.
Okay.
I don't know.
Whoa.
Bye.
I no longer push.
Uh...
I'm pushing cart.
Oh!
Goodbye.
I could eat this thing, probably.
Uh, you're only here.
There's cart duty.
Right there, right there, right there.
To the shield.
Oh, I got you.
Wait, that wall, by the wall?
Oh.
I had to freeze on someone.
A nice, deep freeze.
Thanks for the shield.
Ooh.
Be strong together.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Shoot me through that wall.
I could shoot me through that wall.
Thank you.
I could not move my position.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Nice.
That broke is so fast.
I like the balls.
We're doing it.
Oh, portal?
What the fuck?
Oh, he did the clip.
He did the funny.
Yeah, yeah.
He used to do that so much in ranked back in the day.
It kind of works sometimes too.
Because nobody does it anymore.
Wait, Raccoon's low.
Nice.
I'm hitting him.
I got him, I got him.
You're going left side, yeah.
Wait, Luna, Luna.
Nice.
Kill.
Luger's trying to make a cliff farm right now.
Wait, where the fuck are you?
Nah, he fucking body blocked it.
Oh, no.
That's evil.
He's got drone.
Got you?
There's a mag behind us, by the way.
Nah, Hawkeye is too powerful.
He's pretty strong.
Or is this because it might just be Shraff.
It's just a team up.
Team up is not strong right now.
Yeah, that team up is so strong, actually.
It's crazy.
Thank you for the ramp, Groot.
Oh, nice.
It's a really big ult.
It's really big.
Oh, I got you.
I'm gonna one tap the Luna right now.
Fucking strange in my face.
Here you go.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Where I lived.
They're alive.
Look at those rockets.
He could be there.
Hey, I'm moving the objective.
Come on.
Hawkeye on top.
Can we push him?
Yeah, there's an Ultron and Hawkeye on top.
Oh, he's a shot.
He's one.
I'm popping my ult in their back lane.
I'm going now.
Booger, booger, booger.
That's right.
Yeah, he got my flank.
Get out, get out, get out.
I'm damage boosting.
And now I'm scared.
Dead.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, there's a guy.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm gonna win, I'm gonna win.
Wait, lock it.
Job's not done.
Yay!
Oh, I'm mad.
Done.
Let's go.
It's just Ultron carry, chat.
I'm telling you.
I mean, you killed Shurfor, that was pretty sick.
Feel me?
So, like, what do you think about that Hawkeye team up?
Yo, it's insane.
That's too good.
Like, you can shoot it through walls, and if you hit someone that you have, like, LS of, it's just a guaranteed kill.
Unless they get, like, care from their tank.
Yeah.
It's insane.
I wonder how much Ultron charge...
I forgot I had the frozen cheat.
He hit five of us.
Guys, I have...
I wonder how much he got there.
I haven't touched Rivals, like, a lot this week, so I already forgot about my frozen...
Like, the Ultron team up is the only team up that I keep forgetting I have.
What else wants to guess?
I touched Rivals, like, twice this week.
One was yesterday night, checking out everything.
And then, um...
And the other time was, like, warming up for this.
But, like, to be fair, I didn't feel threatened.
That's the thing.
I didn't feel threatened enough to, like, use it.
Did BP get changed at all?
He's exactly the same, right?
He's exactly the same, bro.
They do not like that character.
Now I like Jeff.
I feel bad for all the Jeff mains watching me play Jeff.
I need a good Ultron game here, because my last one was...
Whoa!
That's where it goes!
Not the greatest.
Wait, can I go back?
I can't go back.
You are what?
You are bad.
No, you are ass group.
It says you.
I forgot about it.
I think Jeff can be really good.
But, in rank.
In rank.
In rank high elo.
With a coordinated team.
We're not coordinated enough for Jeff at the moment.
Like, if we're all stacked up, then I think Jeff will be really good.
Where is my torch, bro?
Yo, uh...
I spawned on the wrong side of the map or something.
I don't know.
You know, new map bugs.
All good, that happened.
It happens.
Eh.
Oh, good.
Oh!
Wait, you're still alive!
Nevermind.
Wait, Surecore is doing weird stuff back here.
He's always doing weird stuff.
Wait, he rezzed.
He's rezzing.
It was like a pink.
It was a pink thing right there.
I definitely was behind that wall.
He's dead.
Dead.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Handle it.
Dead.
I've got you guys.
Don't worry.
He's one.
Oh.
He's so low.
I got snowflake on him too.
Overkill.
Oh, wait.
There's someone behind us.
Surecore is behind.
Hold on.
No, no, no, no, no.
It hurts.
Is he still behind?
He is.
Yes, I'm terrified.
Okay, later.
Okay, dude.
Now, why is Surecore doing the Gilbert noodle right now?
That was crazy.
He did tweet out he was just gonna fling.
The entire time.
Insane.
Oh, wait.
There he is.
He's like right here.
You got this.
Kuro, I believe.
He's not capable.
No, no, no.
I believe.
You can win me on here.
Okay, okay.
I'm going back.
I believe.
I'll heal you through it.
Yeah, I'm really trying here.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, wait.
He missed.
I'm killing you guys.
I don't know if we're gonna make it through.
Alright.
Oh, Necro's got that.
You got this, right?
If I go um yum, will I die instantly?
Oh, he fucking took the portal!
That's shitter!
I didn't even realize there was a portal there.
Oh, not the tank?
I'll do it.
Yep.
Maybe shooting at...
I'm missing somehow?
I don't know if that's possible.
Dude, call me crazy, but I feel like Ultron's left leg could be better.
You're bad.
Really underwhelming.
You are bad.
Got you guys.
I can't believe it.
You're fine.
I think.
You're not fine.
Sorry.
Got me?
Giant.
Okay, I have to reload.
No!
How did that pull me?
That's crazy.
That is a lot of damage.
Goodbye.
Ooh, the Wolverine.
Ooh.
That's smart.
Come on, I'm right here.
No, that's insane.
Hey, what did he do?
Why did he have to magle you like that?
Who did he do that?
Ron, I'll tell you, first of all, that was straight ping, all right?
He must be playing from Europe or something, because...
No, he is.
He's EU.
Oh, yeah.
Because I was behind that wall, but whatever.
Extermination!
Never thought I'd miss him.
What?
Yo, you CC him, you CC him, you can't come out.
Warlock's sniping me, Warlock's sniping me.
Where the fuck is Warlock?
I hate him.
I'm gonna fuck this up again.
I'm gonna try to beat here.
Sure.
Chat, tell me who Warlock is, bro.
What?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Cook him, cook him, cook him.
I've got enough of this.
Oh, no, he came back!
He came back!
Us, us, us, us, us, us, us, us, us, us.
Wait, I didn't do nothing.
I didn't do nothing.
Okay.
Oh.
Let's go.
I can't lose a group turn around.
I don't know.
Wait, where are you, Gru?
I'm following you.
I was following you!
Oh, the arch is getting closer.
This is so underwhelming.
Hey, Agent, give me a toss.
Press C, press C, and then give me a toss.
Wait.
Oh, man.
There he is.
Did I go through walls?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Back, back, back, back, back.
Oh!
So many walls.
Wait, there's a...
Good heals, good heals.
There's a rocket just right there.
I can't out-damage the rocket heals, guys.
Here we go.
Agent, use the team up.
I out-damaged the rocket heals.
There we go.
Give me a toss.
Throw me, bro.
There we go.
Ooh!
Oh, nice!
Oh, there's a flanker, flanker!
Nah.
It's alright.
He's trying to go for me and he whiffed.
That's crazy.
I'm gonna try...
We'll pay.
I'm gonna try Loki.
Wait, let's race bait Boger Guru.
Let's just go.
Where's he at?
I don't know.
He's just running him.
He's main on the payload.
Almost.
He's getting jungled!
Oh my god!
Wait, there's an Adam flanking?
Adam flanking again?
Kill him, kill him, kill him, kill him.
Melt him, melt him.
He's gone.
After reload.
Oh, no!
Thank you.
Adam's still flanking, by the way.
Nice, Wolverine!
You like that?
Give me a toss.
I don't like the way you asked if I like that.
Oh my god.
He's still up to behind us.
Is it not central enough?
Or what?
Oh my god.
Toss me, toss me.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I'm very low on health.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
Yeah, yeah.
So, I'll be honest with you.
They have to be focused on me, bro.
They have to be.
I'm a threat.
I just realized I didn't do my thing.
Hello.
Oh, you just copied iron fist?
Yeah, I didn't have to, like, confirm thing.
So, I instantly spammed.
I was like, whoops.
You're going crazy though, you're still alive.
I don't know how to survive, but hello.
You actually live.
Hello, I'm back.
I need heals though.
They go.
Time to vanish.
Oh, wow.
They're like waiting for me.
Oh, I'm fine.
Don't mind me.
Hey, Mag.
Mag on points.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
My death was pretty exaggerated.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Who's drawn?
Who?
Got you?
I'mma throw you.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I got somebody.
Oh, nice.
You gobbled.
Oh, unlucky.
We're going in.
Oh, he's dead.
That's okay over there?
Can't tell.
Oh.
I don't know.
Maybe?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Hi, Voros.
We'll be farmed.
Time to vanish.
Nice.
Don't give them another inch.
Or else.
Better start that vehicle.
Oh.
There you go.
There is.
You went for me with that.
He's going to fight for that one.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait, no, no, no.
Did we just see nine?
Oh, we just see nine.
Guys, did we see nine?
Did we just see nine?
We might have seen nine for half the point, bro.
What?
That's nice.
Oh, my God.
Who's seen nine us?
Who's job is it?
Guys, it was content, right?
Yeah, it's probably my fault.
Yeah, we're doing it for content, right, guys?
Yeah.
Holy shit.
Do we go another, guys?
I'm down.
I don't know if I can handle another.
Yeah, it was kind of intense.
Yeah, my back hurt.
Let's do another though.
All right.
Oh, that was something.
That's unreal.
Wait, was it sure for that C9 us?
Oh, my God.
That is crazy going for C9s in this.
Yeah, the XC9s.
C9s us.
Crazy.
I'll play...
Star-Lord.
Oh, the team up.
How's the team up?
Yeah, the team up is...
Star-Lord.
It's really good.
It seems like a necessity, to be honest.
Oh, all right.
I guess because, like, he'll have another form to heal, too.
Because I think he lacks the heals without it.
Yeah, this would be my last game, guys.
And then I gotta go to the tech check for a meet and greet.
For Fanime.
It's a busy day.
Oh, you guys have been enjoying the preview.
And everything.
But I've been doing all right.
I might be talking too much.
I will say, I'm liking this patch a lot more.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, previous one.
As a dive player, I don't know if I like this patch.
It's also awesome, though.
As a support player, I love this patch.
Oh, there's...
There's a nice world, bro.
Oh, you're in triple?
Uh...
Yup, they are.
Yeah.
Cause I see...
I see Mantis.
Oh!
Ready?
How'd you get it?
That was fast.
I could do that.
Oh, I can't get to you, Gru.
Nice.
Wait, I hear a portal.
Oh, that was you.
Okay.
I was like, whose portal is that?
Wait, can I get out from here?
He's behind us.
Wait, who is?
There's a Gru behind us.
Oh.
Yeah, he is.
Oh, unlucky.
Wait, he's low.
The floor is low.
Oh, no.
Copy.
No.
Don't call me over.
I'm leaving.
Have you used the team up yet?
Yeah, I did.
I did.
I like the heels for it.
Oh my...
Nice.
Oh.
Holy shit.
Oh, I'm...
Oh, I'm so close.
I shot you my screen.
It's probably ping.
Wait, I think it's just ping.
Yeah, mine's like 130.
Kinda high.
Nice.
Wait, there's a Skrogo behind us.
Yeah.
There you go.
I'm just like, on the low ground, guys.
Main.
Oh my god.
Do you guys?
No.
Fuck.
Jesus.
Oh my god, you guys are taking so much damage.
Yeah, I'm trying to heal him.
So much damage.
Yeah.
I think I need this.
No.
He's just one.
The parking transport's so fucking hard.
No!
Okay.
I got you.
It's like we're playing a pro team.
This is crazy.
I'm gonna copy...
Just like, make sure it doesn't die.
Oh, I might need...
I got you.
I'm holding.
Don't worry.
You got your...
You got his?
Uh...
Yup.
There you go.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'm on point.
Let's go.
Oh, you can be on point, actually.
Yeah, I'm on point.
Yeah.
Only 60 seconds left.
Extermination!
Oh my god.
Did they griddle?
You're good, you're good.
You just exterminate.
Ultra on top left.
He's low, he's low.
Ultra low.
Wow.
Got you.
Or low.
Or low top left.
Yeah, we're getting flanked.
Yup, they're kinda everywhere.
Wait, I'm getting shot by...
Oh!
I didn't see the squirrel, bro.
Touching 20.
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
Guys, lock it in, lock it in.
I'm coming back soon.
Don't worry, I'm at my C.
Nice, Ray.
To the screws.
Got him.
Oh, I'm one, I'm one.
Keep fighting until we have a winner.
I got alternate.
Nice.
Let's go.
Yay!
Oh, whoops.
I'll try...
Oh my god, you're so hard to hit on that hero.
What the hell?
You're doing crazy moves in Star Lord.
Oh, now Chris, can you heal me real quick?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Thanks.
Should I be the...
Oh, ready to heal.
You know what?
You should probably be the payload, Princess.
You have your ult.
Yeah, that's true.
Oh my god!
Oh!
It knocked me out!
They locked me out!
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Yeah, I'll be on payload.
Fire!
He's in there!
He's in there.
We are undefeatable!
Slow, Boker, slow!
Oh, I couldn't get too bad.
I'm okay.
I must fight my programming and assist the audience.
Like, what the fuck is the group doing up here?
Extroviral!
Did he do that?
I'm not.
But he missed.
We're so low.
Holy shit.
Wait.
Oh, clip.
It's clip time.
Oh, can you heal me?
Uh, yeah.
Thank you.
It's been hard to hit a flying hero.
Yeah.
I got you.
Wait, why the hell, uh, oh my god.
Didn't need this one.
I bolt.
Hello.
Yo.
My vulgar is low.
You okay.
Thanks.
Do your trick.
Bye.
Yes.
Alright, let's pop up quick for a portal.
Hey.
Are you gonna do a crazy portal?
Maybe.
I wonder what that initial portal was.
Oh.
What kind of clip he was trying to get.
Wait, someone above.
Hello?
Oh, oh.
Not the best.
What is this?
He's behind him.
Yeah, yeah.
I might.
Oh, I'm so low.
Big.
Oh, nice.
Thumbs one.
Okay.
I'm coming on me.
Wait, he swung over here.
It's okay.
He doesn't know I can fly.
What the hell?
Okay, that was... weird.
That is...
That is something.
Good luck.
Oh, no.
I'm so dead.
Oh, that's big.
That's big.
That's real big.
Oh, my God.
That was bad.
Oh, nice.
That's Groodle.
Crazy Groodle.
Wait, who's over here?
Oh, yo.
I got you.
Get the Venom.
There's an Atron right here.
One more clean fight.
We need one more clean fight.
Can we kill the staggers?
Yeah, yeah.
That's big, that's big.
I got you.
Oh.
Yeah, hello top.
Nice.
Only 60 seconds left.
I'm healing you on point.
I have a good spot here.
Actually.
Wait, Bulger low?
Nice.
Yay!
Chee-chees!
Let's go.
We're too clean, team.
We're too clean.
Chee-chees.
We're the ghosts.
We might be the best to ever.
We might be the best to ever do it.
True.
Actually, man.
The best to ever do it.
What is that?
Three in a row?
Oh, no.
We see nine last game.
That don't count.
I mean, it's like half a win because we were keeping them in spawn.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know what I mean?
We're just having so much fun killing them that we didn't notice.
True.
Yes.
Damn, it's already...
It's already seven.
Time flew.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's fun as hell.
Time flies and you're having fun, am I right?
You sure are, man.
It was good playing with y'all though, for real.
Yeah.
Chee-chees, guys.
Chee-chees, great play with all of you.
Chee-chees, everybody.
Chee-chees, guys.
Chee-chees.
All right, y'all.
All right, bye-bye.
See y'all on ranked.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
True, true.
Peace.
All right, that was fun.
I had a fun time checking out the new, um, checking out the new updates and everything.
Oh.
He knows.
It's almost feeding time, but like, we're one hour away.
Yeah, I had really fun playing Ultron.
Jeff was like, okay, no.
No.
You see this?
Wait, where is it?
Okay.
Dad, no.
Sorry.
He knows that I'm about to end.
So he's like, that means feeding time.
Usually it's not, because I had, um, he's like an hour behind.
I think, I think Jeff is actually good.
I just think like, you need a coordinated team to play Jeff.
Um, because like, the Storm-Jeff combo is really, really strong.
I was just like, I don't have a lot of playtime on Jeff, but he's, I just think if I have more playtime on- Jeff is literally the only character I lack playtime on for all the strategists.
And I feel like I play Ultron better than Jeff.
When I was trying Jeff, I was like, wait, I think I personally play better on Ultron than Jeff.
Like, I think I was actually playing really well on Ultron.
Like, cause like, I don't know.
Jeff is weird.
He's had such a weird mechanic that it's very, um, hard to like, process it correctly.
Cause his mechanic-wise, his gameplay-wise is very weird.
Uh...
But I think my Ultron was pretty decent.
And, um...
I, I think like...
Yeah, and with Jeff, you need a lot of map knowledge so you can fly- You can like, swim up walls and everything.
I think it's just swimming up walls that throws me off too.
Um...
Yeah, um...
But like, I think like, uh...
I think I just need map knowledge for Jeff.
And I, that map took a while to process.
I don't know where the portals go.
And like, where everybody is when I was playing Jeff.
And like, you need map knowledge and a coordinate team.
I think he can be really scary and high elo and competitive.
Especially for Stormlight.
But it was really fun.
It was really fun checking out the entire new update and everything.
It's like Krakoa all over.
But this is...
It's the worst.
Cause like, it's all metal and gray.
So I was like, at least I could use trees and be like, there it is.
Cause that's where I had to go next.
So it takes a while for me to build up the map knowledge.
But I still had it really fun.
When I started figuring out the map.
It started getting easier and easier for me.
And then I started figuring out stuff.
Um...
And, um...
I think I did pretty well.
Um...
I hope I didn't talk too much.
Cause I realized I was talking a lot.
And I was like, oh...
I feel like everybody was talking to their own chat.
And I was stupid.
I was trying to talk to them.
And I was like, oh, I hope I didn't talk too much.
Sorry guys.
I...
I was like, wait.
Am I supposed to talk to my chat too?
I...
Yeah, but...
It was really, really fun.
Cause I was like, Necros, I got you.
No response.
I was like, it's alright.
That's cool.
Just know you're alive because of me.
Just know that.
Um...
Yeah, and then...
But I had a lot of fun.
It was a great opportunity.
For those who wanna check out Marvel Rivals.
Please feel free to click on my link.
That's pinned in the chat.
Um...
Or do...
Do I have a command for it?
I don't think I have a command for it.
Haha.
But...
Um...
But it was really fun.
And I really enjoyed having...
Being able to check out the other access.
Being invited by the Marvel Rivals team.
Huge shout out to them for inviting me.
Um...
Uh...
New updates every...
Almost...
I think like every month now.
There's gonna be new updates almost every month now.
Uh...
New hero updates too.
Um...
So...
Uh...
But yeah.
I hope you guys enjoy it.
Uh...
I'm glad that...
The teams were...
Still evil...
Like...
The other team...
Um...
The other team also like...
Like you know were not tri-harding and everything.
And we were all just like vibing.
So that was great.
Because like...
Obviously we have newer...
Not new players.
But obviously players that don't play the game as much.
Uh...
So it was nice that everyone adjusted to chill and everything.
And just like you know...
Have fun and everything.
Uh...
So it was really, really fun.
But yeah, it was great checking out the new map, checking out the new heroes, showing you guys everything.
Hawkeye is back!
Hawkeye is definitely back, back.
Yeah, like, the moment Gale was on Hawkeye, it killed everybody with my Luna power-ups.
That was pretty scary.
Ultron, I think, either needs a third support or, like, need a main healer.
Because, like, he does not do that much healing.
IMO.
He definitely does not do enough healing.
Unless you have the Iron Man team-up.
But even then, even with the Iron Man team-up, it's still, like, it's still not that much.
So I think, like, he's a great DPS, though.
Um, DPS is, like, pretty strong.
Um, I think- I honestly think Jeff can be really good.
Like, I know, like, when I was playing Jeff, it was not working really well.
But also, like, it's because, like, I think it's because our team was- we're all, like, doing solos and stuff.
We're all, like, you know, they were all doing, like, like, clips and, like, gameplay, like, you know, trying to clips- do clips and clip farm and stuff like that.
But I think Jeff can be really, really good.
It's just that my team was uncoordinated to make- to uncoordinated to make Jeff work.
Um, but in a coordinated environment, he is really- I think he is really, really good.
Um, due to the fact that, like, especially if it's broad comp.
If it's broad comp and not, uh, if it's broad comp, um, it would have been really strong.
And if we had a- we did the Jeff-Storm team up better, it could be really, really strong.
I mean, the enemy team pulled off Jeff-Storm really well.
I- me- I think it was, like, me and Necros, we were not coordinated enough.
I was, like- and then they had a Punisher.
They instantly knew how to counter.
They were, like, Punisher time.
I was, like, guys, I need someone- Mom, pick me up!
Mom!
I was, like, Mom, pick me up!
Please!
I was, like, no!
I was, like, where is Mom?
Where is she?
Um, and then Mom was too late.
She was too late to pick me up.
Shoot.
But, um, I had a lot of fun, though.
Um, and I hope a lot of people had fun watching.
Uh, I have to go now to do my meet and greet at Fanime.
Um, but thank y'all for coming.
Uh, if you guys are new here, my name is DokiBurn.
I usually stream on YouTube, so please check me out there if you're a new viewer.
Um, do we have any new viewers in chat that just recently came in to check me out?
Thank- welcome!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Any new viewers in chat?
Yeah?
That's right!
Show yourself!
But yeah, thank you guys.
Um, uh, thank you all for coming.
I really, really appreciate it.
Welcome, new dragoons.
But yes, check me out on YouTube!
Exclamation point YouTube.
I usually stream there.
Um, today I was streaming on Twitch because there was a sponsor on Twitch.
And they wanted me on here on this platform for today.
Uh, because everyone else was on here.
And if you guys wanna follow me on Twitter, usually I tweet out whenever I'm streaming on Twitch.
So, check me out on Twitter as well.
Um, and also, um, you wanna support me via other memes?
I have merch.
Uh, I have the custom PC case.
If you do exclamation point hiya.
I also have, um, a new music video out right now.
Uh, of my 3D concert.
So yeah!
And I sang Five Nights at Freddy's.
I literally just uploaded it today.
I just dropped it because I got the video.
I got the 3D video.
I finally got the video today.
I got both Last Cup of Coffee and Five Nights at Freddy's.
And then I just was like, you know what?
I got it today.
Bam!
There you go.
Surprise!
At 9 in the morning.
At 9 in the fucking morning.
Boom!
Surprise!
Uh...
Um...
Um, but I will have an actual waiting room for Last Cup of Coffee.
So yeah.
Um...
Um, but yes.
Anyway.
Thank you everyone for coming.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get them around to get that blood flowing.
Any of you, stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!